two here we are baby
just like i promised on
well today's tuesday but it's coming out
on wednesday two
episodes a week two episodes a week
here we are i kept my promise even
though i should remind you
that there are no sponsors today this is
just
love for the game that's how we roll
baby
although i would appreciate you going to
either h3h3shop.com and buying our
commemorative
200 episodes t-shirt
which let's be honest doesn't really
commemorate 200 episodes at all now that
i'm looking at it
just a picture of me of my gut as the
earth
i guess it reminds me of all the taste
that this
is but like r kelly on there or like i
don't know all this stuff kind of we
talked about the memes but hey this is
the shirt we've got all right
or because we don't have sponsors keep
the energy level high
you can go to teddyfresh.com
and get any number of excellent items
there so many excellent items to
make you happy and feel beautiful okay
first i would like to tell you all
something very urgent and important
i have been playing the ghost of
shishimi
tsushima and i have to tell
you all i've probably been paying for
maybe like five maybe six
hours i don't know but so far
i have to say really good i give it
my personal approval i like the game
i don't play but i like watching it's so
good i highly recommend it to everybody
um it's like skyrim
samurai style but the story and the act
and i i just like usually i'm so annoyed
by video game dialogue
and story and like the mannerisms of the
face and everything but this one i'm
loving everything about it the combat
the dialogue
when he gets you get to see his ass when
he goes in a hot spring
i didn't see that yeah you haven't seen
that
yeah like that didn't he it's really
beautiful
too beautiful unbelievable so there you
have it
highly recommend now i want to start the
day off with something light
and fun you know we've been doing this
kind of story of the year segment
so ela you i don't know did you watch
this hela
i did yeah but um i was dying man this
guy
so i'll just play the damn thing story
of the year
start us off with a laugh block dozens
of calls after her ex-partner allegedly
took her phone number and plastered on
polls here around the cbd
telling people to call up and
impersonate chewbacca
for a chance to win 100 this would be
the most childish breakup i've
ever had like all you had to do was be
mature and go
i don't love you anymore i want to move
on the calls have been waking her and
her three young children up at odd hours
in the evening
and they're yet to stop
well i'm getting phone calls at really
strange hours of the night
that's the best that's the best
this guy should be whatever he's doing
he should have a career in comedy
i never heard of such a thing in my life
it's awful too but it's like
perfectly awful because people are just
making chewbacca
calling you and making chewbacca sounds
oh so funny
you paused it like slightly before the
ending okay
forced to call back the wannabe wookies
and tear down the posters
wow so now so the people are calling
trying to 100 bucks and then they get
some random woman calling back say
tear down that poster it's like lady
where's my hundred
did i win or not
so shout out to uh
it sounded so good did this guy so he
must not hate her that much
or maybe he's just he's like a um
he's like a good-natured hater
because usually when you break up you
imagine clothes on the sidewalk or
tires being slashed i mean a dirty
breakup right like she's very upset
this guy's like nah chewbacca calling
you all day
it's pretty creative it depends how long
he keeps it up frankly
is this like a weekend event or is this
like i'm gonna keep this up for
years nah i can't imagine that
because then we're talking some real
revenge
you change your change your number yeah
but he finds it
they have three kids together you think
he doesn't know her number
oh i don't know if he has the kids uh
he'll find the number ela let's assume
he can find the number and he keeps it
going for 10
years
you're just taking it too far right now
and um
yeah we'll move on yes
this is drama that has shook
the next story it shook the gaming world
to its very
core
joe rogan king of enlightenment
the greatest thinker of our generation
has come down hard
on video games and
it's been trending all over twitter
people have been saying
joe how could you do this to us
gamers are your foundation
and you dare speak ill of me i don't
feel that funny when i'm just looking at
ian's face blankly and un
and without any joy or any pleasure at
all
ian's just sitting there i'm trying to
be funny as i can be and ian's going all
i see is ian's face going
you are bullying me i gotta minimize
this because
at yeah um i don't think we need to have
it open
no it's killing me it's like the
toughest crowd ever
it's like being on stage and everyone's
just staring at you it's like you feel
so unfunny
i'm kind of sick it's okay you shouldn't
have been it's not your fault i mean
you didn't know you were being watched
that's a weird sound bite zack i gotta
just say
oh that was that was a sound bite that
was a zombie
if you sound by him saying that was a
weird sound bite
then this cycle of insanity will never
stop
no it will not oh my god i thought it
was real
so ian when you pick your his sound by
choices are so interesting he'll just
play me going like
go i'll say something like oh yes
uh yeah i had lunch and he'll sound by
but that's what's
so genius is because why would he sound
like that
and then we just we have no idea who's
talking
yeah genius is one way to look at it i
think it's great and he's down by him
saying i'm ate lunch or whatever i
appreciate that thank you
see that was a sound bite because i've
heard that one
ian when you're really talking you
should do like this you go
because he doesn't have anything like
that i know that
but if i do that he'll sound bite that
[Laughter]
he'll sound by you saying that
this is all a sound bite i'm not
actually talking
all right enough of this joe rogan
has shook the gaming world
as if he was atlas you know how atlas
holds
the world world on his shoulders joe
rogan was atlas
and the world was video games and he
said and he did a super suplex
flipping sidekick and smashed it because
he does mma
anyway here's what he said this was like
a big debate on twitter
and i'll show you the clip and then we
will discuss
seek refuge in drugs or video games or
something that stimulates them
and video games are a real problem their
real problem you know why because
they're
[ __ ] fun and you don't yeah well i'm
i have a real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right
it's like you could do like like martial
arts right you could learn jiu jitsu
you get obsessed by jiu jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt you're
moving up yeah
you're doing well you're thinking like i
might be able to open my own school one
day that confidence yeah if i have a
hundred students and those hundred
students are paying me x amount of
dollars per month i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun and you don't
or you could just be playing [ __ ]
video games three years later you could
be that same kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vicks whatever the [ __ ] game is
you know next xbox game to come out do
you think there's
just as many people who are three years
later just doing jiu jitsu
yeah there's actually there's probably
way more opportunities for a career in
gaming than jiu-jitsu
that's why the whole argument that he's
making didn't make any sense to me
but um i think he's probably just not
really aware
of the scene of streamers and
the gaming the amount of money the
sports and all that the gaming uh
renaissance there's kind of been a
gaming renaissance in the past five
years where
actually it seems like if you are really
good at a game
like unusually good at a game
you can almost certainly make a living
doing it now if you just stream
because enough people are going to want
to watch you play
you're going to make a living from it
probably even the whole ecosystem around
it of
uh you know youtube channels about
pro gaming and you know the commentary
and all that i mean but a lot of money
in it
i love in his analogy that being a
taekwondo teacher is like the pinnacle
of success
i mean how often does that happen how
many taekwondo teacher successful tag
condo teachers are there in the country
like like i don't know a thousand i mean
i don't know
maybe more but i mean it seems like such
a niche job
but you know i do
feel like video gamers
get more [ __ ] than people with other
hobbies
for example that it's like a
generational bias
i mean look it's the same thing it's
like we all got hobbies we're all gonna
[ __ ] die what does it matter in the
end you know what i mean
it's like dude you did taekwondo i
played video games for three i mean
who [ __ ] cares ultimately i think
it's just the lack of physical movement
well that i agree with and being like
physically
in the same room with other people or
physically
engaged in anything i think that's what
is their problem
i think that's very important
and i do think well if you're going to
spend three years doing taekwondo or
video games obviously
if it was up to me which one i enjoyed
more i wish i would be doing taekwondo
because you'll be jacked
you'll be able to kick beat up bullies
and um yeah that'd be way better for you
probably mentally physically and
everything but
i mean mentally i don't know seems like
video games do
i mean like confidence wise okay because
video games do require a lot of
focus that's why i feel like brain power
separately if you look at video games
gamers catch so much [ __ ] there's such a
stigma against being a video gamer
like just take when i was a kid i would
sit at home
and play everquest i was [ __ ] just
so into everquest as a kid but every
time i was playing that game
my dad was on his ass watching sports
and somehow what i was doing was was
wrong
and what he was doing was fine because
if you're a sports fan
you're just a good old american you know
it's a national past time
but if you're playing video games you're
degenerate no it's because they have
this
ideal in their head of what activities
should be like they remember themselves
playing outside with a ball
in the sun a ball versus you sitting in
a dark room
yeah it doesn't look good it looks
depressing
[Music]
but ultimately he's right i mean it's a
waste of time but you know
isn't living is kind of just a waste of
time ultimately what is it yeah
i mean just just existing is kind of
what we have
we have two employees that have kids and
i've heard both of them say
that they're worried because their kids
just want to play video games all day
yeah it's a thing that i see a lot yeah
i wonder what to do about that though i
mean it is a problem
but like if you go back 50 years i mean
i'm sure there was something else like
oh i'm so worried
i swear to god people used to say oh i'm
worried my kid just reads all day
well i mean i feel like i would
understand the first generation of
parents having to go through this and
being worried
like your parents let's say yeah but you
turned out all right
so i think at this point we don't need
to worry about it
well if theodore's in his room 12 hours
a day playing video games i mean i would
be worried
sure i would be where i would i would be
wanting to like you know
what i think you need to do is start
playing the game with him
you understand it and then
once he sees that you like it then he
hates it that's not cool you have to
hijack all of their hobbies
so it becomes uncool and then when he
picks up a hobby that you like then
you're like oh i don't get that
that hobby is just weird to me i think
that's the thing i think
i think you as a parent should try to
understand what it is they're doing and
do it with them
mm-hmm you know but people always say oh
video games is anti-social well that's
not really true
not true and then like if you compare
video games to like sports video games
are very active you're reading
you're walking through a 3d landscape
which you say is good for your brain
you're you know there's there's stuff
that you're it's way more engaging
i mean the i think the main problem is
that people need to get more physical
activity
right in their daily routine that i will
not
uh debate it and especially i can tell
like when i was living in israel you
have a lot of walking involved in your
day
just going to do random things usually
there's a lot more things that are
walkable
i don't know well you're talking about
la i think i don't know what it's like
in other
places other states well new york you
live there
yeah but new york is very unique um i
think it just depends
if you're in the city or this i mean it
really depends
i can tell in la you really need to make
an effort
a conscious decision of going out and
getting some
physical movement yes otherwise it just
doesn't happen you just
your body just had trip what's it called
atrophies
atrophies atrophy atrophies
i atrophy away no but i mean yeah he's
he's right actually i'm not even gonna
dispute him it is a waste of time but i
guess what i would counters with
is literally everything is a waste of
time mr joe rogan
and i will further say yeah you can be
addicted to anything i mean really
you could take anything too far i think
the way he phrased it
made uh a lot of people miss some
context too because he says
he talks about video games he says i got
a real problem with video games right he
was actually talking about himself yeah
he was a video game addict yeah so right
but if you didn't know that it just
sounds like
he's like he's got a real problem with
video games
look how it cups his head though the
thing
but why i just don't know why you can't
just enjoy it like anything i mean the
guy's obviously balanced his life
i think he's just said that once he gets
into it well for you
it's a waste of time because video games
is not
his profession so anytime that he's
spending on a video game it could be
doing
it could be writing material for you i
think i think right and i think people
who feel that that sounds apply for me i
would never get into a video game right
now
i have a million other things i'd rather
do there you go so don't play video
games
for me it's it is a waste of time so
don't pick it up don't play it but don't
judge people who ain't got [ __ ] to do in
their life
you know that joke they go i think it
was a cat williams joke he's talking
about smoking weed he goes
if you're broke and you ain't got no job
i don't know why you're not smoking weed
obviously i don't smoke weed and i you
know but but the point is like hey
if that's what you got then lean on it
baby
and get go to town you know what i'm
saying get that paragon 1
500 and diablo
so ultimately what did joe say was it
super offensive
no was it interesting uh no
you know was uh anything really was
should this clip even really have been a
point of contention at all
probably not anything to add yola
probably not the biggest take though is
that
dome dude look at that look at it i
really don't get
what you're saying what how do you not
see that's funny
that's got to be my new desktop
it's just a soft material so but isn't
it funny how they're made with like
two cushions here and then like because
he has no hair it's just
it's so perfect i don't know why you
don't find that funny
it looks like a star wars droid he
doesn't
do anything to me dude
that's my new desktop forever anyway
that's that
joe rogan is in deep [ __ ] with gamers
and they are coming for
him another uh headline of the year
what were our two previous headlines of
the year there was um
so just to recap amy schumer's husband
is uncircumcised according to jake
gyllenhaal
correct the other one was jordan
heard pooped in johnny depp's bed
and i heard jordan hurt you jordan hurt
amber hurt amber heard
pooped and johnny depp's bed well no the
headline was that
him and her both accuse each other
of pooping and peeing all over the house
which is way more epic
that you're right it's like yeah you
pooped in my bed i'm gonna poop in your
shoes mega doo doo
right um so here is another contender
for headline of the year are you ready
ela
elon musk challenges johnny depp johnny
depp
making another appearance and headline
of the year
elon musk challenges johnny depp to a
cage fight
over alleged amber herd affair threats
[Music]
should i read that again yes elon musk
challenges johnny depp
to cage fight over alleged amber herd
affair
threats i didn't know that elon was with
amber turd apparently
they both get around elon is like
[ __ ] everybody it seems like
it's crazy you know elon has like six
kids yeah i just learned that all boys
too right he's got the strong
boy gene apparently the alpha
yeah he's alpha as [ __ ] oh and another
thing i learned is that so
with his first wife he had first twins
and then
triplets that's how he has so many kids
ah
that's crazy shredder's worried
oh my god that's so psycho to have twins
and then triplets
anyway elon musk denies sleeping with so
johnny
uh do you think he's too old to go by
johnny
johnny i just say johnny it feels like a
a youthful name
i don't know it's johnny depp right
iconic yeah
john depp doesn't have the same no
mysticism
johnny jenny uh
so elon musk johnny depp accused elon of
cheating
on amber before they were separated and
in response
elon said he denied it and challenged
him to a cage fight
for threat because johnny depp
threatened to cut off his manhood
elon said i definitely was not having an
affair with amber while she was married
to johnny this is totally false
musk a 29 year old father of six laughed
when asked about other claims
including that he had a threesome with
heard
and model cara delevingne did i say that
you said musk at 29
yeah confused what is wrong with me dude
musk a 49 year old
father of six a little more allegedly
had a threesome with herd
and cara delevingne
anyone want to correct me on that
uh cara delevingne television you got it
right the first time yeah i think
yeah um props that my man elon
damn i mean apparently it's just rumors
i don't know
props to elon that one
i bet you he did man i bet you he did
that's crazy
imagine this imagine you told elon watch
this
young elon musk imagine you told young
elon musk
at age like whatever he is here
look at this photo of him imagine you
told this young man
the nerdiest [ __ ] you've ever
seen who's already bald
that he was going to have a threesome
with amber heard and cara
delevingne
he would he would have said dude no
[ __ ] way
you would ask so what does it take to
get there and you would be like probably
getting to mars and um
oh yeah oh you'll have a threesome with
those two when you fly to
mars he's like don
i hear you buddy um
he insists he only dated heard after she
split from depp
he wants to bury the hatchet but musk
who's worth more than 66 billion
chuckled when the times asked about
relevant court documents
that dub depp had dubbed him
the mollusk
got him what is that supposed to mean
it's like a lizard a mollusk
no it's not a snake or something no
isn't it a moleskin
yeah yeah exactly some sort of
invertebrate
oh yeah see i stand corrected in my
infinite wisdom yes alas i am wrong
that is such a weak um dude elon mollusk
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
well yeah i hope he recovers from the
situation musk told the paper
he had a far more unexpected response
when asked about text messages the power
of the caribbean started allegedly sent
threatening to slice off his dick
if j he said if johnny wants a cage
fight just let me know
musk told the times giggling
so there you go maybe we'll have the
fight of the century
musk is a pretty big dude though he's
like 6'3 so i'm pretty sure he would
stomp little johnny
[Music]
johny depp sounds like a little bit of a
psycho
yeah dude for sh i mean sounds
looks johnny depp height
510 i mean normal normal size guy
elon musk 6'2
four inches on him i think elon would
stomp him i think johnny would take him
really without a weapons just just
hand-to-hand combat
yeah i think i think johnny he's got
that craziness in him
yeah yeah he's probably exercising too i
don't know hold on elon musk
age let's do this 49 years old musk
versus johnny depp is
57 you guys 57
49. elon will stomp him yeah you're
probably right
he'll collaborate if they were the same
age though i think johnny dipped
i disagree i'm still team johnny 57
years old bro you think he's going to
take out dude you know what you're wrong
cybernetic implants bro look at rocky
six
he was like 60 when he beat like a 35
year old wait what he was in rocky six
no no no no oh that's a movie song wait
zach
that's your whole thesis for why johnny
will win
150 yes
you know he's got a point i scored
johnny
johnny would kick his ass i mean like
yoda was like super old
yeah [ __ ] you was like 900 years old bro
that's true
you know what my money's on johnny depp
[ __ ] it let's
let's send bob barker into the ring how
old is he johnny depp also has the power
of the golden doubloon curse
on his side i don't think he can be
killed by mortal man so
oh the uh curse of the black pearl right
exactly there you go
i think fred alfredo would take them all
oh my god he would when he turns out
franco
oh yeah alfredo because you guys know
alfredo's from the street he's a street
dog
so every once in a while he's like the
sweetest nicest
most precious dog in the world but every
once in a while like he'll get something
he's not supposed to have
either food or a chew or like
a piece of plastic or like a bottle from
theodore
and if you try to take it away from you
he will go
to full on uh
it's like we call it alfreco alfrico he
goes like
his eyes go crazy and he attacks no
warning he'll he he's bitten both of us
oh whoa and then he gets he goes
like that and he tries to bite you and
you just have to back off
because whoa but then he um he always
feels guilty and comes and cuddles you
afterwards oh but the first time it
happened i was like
whoa what the f but now i just don't
mess with him when he's in a freaking
mode
sometimes i'll take a shirt and i'll
throw it at him because he'll attack the
shirt
and he'll just he'll kind of get out of
the alfreco mode
so i throw a shirt or i poke him with
something he goes
oh my god and then i keep prodding him
with something else because i don't want
him
he's got something he's not supposed to
have and then eventually he like snapped
out of it so that's my
wow that's pretty shocking he really is
like one of the sweetest dogs
no it's super weird it's super crazy
makes sense though like you said he
probably had to
scrap yeah as a young man out on the
street he's got some real street trauma
he was starving
oh yeah he was starving his tail is
broken too and i don't know how that
happened so
he's definitely been through a lot his
tail has grown like
crooked you know it's like straight and
then just get off to the side like it
was broke right in half
poor guy yeah yeah he's such a sweet boy
we love him okay well so
johnny depp really you guys think he'll
take you on okay 100
well i'd like to see that fight if it
happens
57 that's like hit breaking hey joe
uh okay here's a great story
prominent influencers are facing
backlash for throwing parties in l.a
amid covet now we talked about this last
week how jake
got a call from tanner fox
tanner said to him dude i've got covid
and i was hanging out with you
all weekend long
um let me pull that up for posterity's
sake
hello yo nice yo man
hey jake hello hey bro
um so i have some i have some bad news
oh man so
we filmed a video about two days ago and
this morning
i woke up and i felt a little bit off so
i went and got a kobe 19 test
and it actually came back positive
[Music]
you're tripping i'm really not lying to
you man i'm being honest
bro so i know i was around you and your
in your team
and again i i just started showing very
small symptoms of it today
but i wanted to call you and i had to
let you know i really just got tested
for it you just got tested did you get
your results back
no i i don't know what to tell you i'm
joking i'm really not joking right now
man i swear
i swear to god
are you are you worried about it
not really we don't care
okay so there so i love that not really
we don't care
so now jake has been exposed to
covid the cdc says that you should
quarantine yourself for two weeks
yes not now anyone
definitely don't leave your house let me
give you multiple choice what do you
think jake paul did after receiving this
news
a quarantine
and call everyone he was in contact with
b
go out and party and not tell anybody
that's a hard that's a thing
so here a ton of influencers went out
and uh partied here we go let's go so
first of all you guys don't understand
jake put out a song
a
no one is wearing a mask why are they
indoors i thought you weren't allowed to
eat indoors
hey my fresh out of london baby
let's go oh family dinner there's
logan blah blah blah tana
so also real quick in tanner's video the
i'm positive video he called logan as
well
and he says he was around him a week ago
from
when he recorded that video and you'll
notice logan is at that dinner too
so both of them have been exposed to the
same guy
and and both of them know that and they
know that guy is positive
i wonder if they didn't even tell each
other when i saw that i thought
maybe logan doesn't know like maybe jake
didn't even tell logan
yeah that's what i was giving him the
doubt because
because logan has get is still having
guests on this part wait that can't be
is logan still having guests on his
podcast in studio
you're sure logan was exposed to this
guy the in the tanner video
if you watch it after the jake paul part
he calls logan
he calls logan now no way yeah
because logan america has oh well he
hasn't done an episode since five days
ago so maybe he is being safe
although when was that video from uh
hey i'll give you the exact time this
last episode was from five days ago
so you can't the video was posted july
15th
this is july 23rd he's sitting in the
small room
dude what the [ __ ] is he doing and i
believe around
the 12 minute mark of tanner's video he
he calls
he calls logan hold on let's watch that
what is wrong with these people i mean
no i mean how can you be
so careless about other people but
you're not even telling uh you have to
tell the other people that like here
this
let's see he's calling logan on youtube
that that is he my guy hey man
listen i really hate to be having this
call with you right now
i haven't you got kobe 19 how did you
know
uh my mom somehow knew
oh i told jake oh
well uh well i hope you get better bro
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] isolate yourself
i i am i'm staying at quarantine for the
next 14 days but i know i haven't seen
you in a week i just started showing
symptoms of it today but i just wanted
to call and make sure your whole team
knows
what uh what's symptom i woke up today
and i was excited
logan just think he's calling to just
check in
he's like i was with you a week ago
you've been exposed because by now
um yeah if they were together a week ago
that would be definitely yeah that would
mean that logan is
accusing less likely yeah high risk he's
like oh well i hope you get better
nothing to do with me dude he's sitting
in a tiny room with these people
i wonder if they all hate uh tanner for
being like
for recording this [ __ ] and putting it
online
because he definitely didn't ask their
permission you might have maybe
you would text them afterwards or even
oh man this is just exhausted because
like this video they don't seem to care
i don't think i think but like this
video is the perfect blueprint for like
following the trail of insanity he's
like here's
everybody i called and you can perfectly
see how they're not taking it seriously
i honestly think they know he was
recording and they just don't care
let me hear this i felt really tired
interesting all right well thanks for
letting me know bro i uh
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for letting me know what the [ __ ]
what is wrong with these guys wait but
he goes oh [ __ ]
isolate see why would he say why would
he say that he knows he's being recorded
why would you even talk like that yeah
like why would he even say
if he thought the guy is just calling to
tell him hey i'm sick
why would you say hey i don't give a
[ __ ] don't you think that's like him
i think he because all these people
later apologized for their party so
no i feel like he didn't know he was
being recorded
if anything he asked after the
conversation
well regardless of the reason he goes
he what is wrong with them dude this is
so insane
wait i didn't know that logan said i
didn't give a [ __ ]
i thought we are wrong no problem man
all right uh well
i hope i hope you're all good uh i
appreciate you though
later he goes uh he goes dude you better
isolate
he's like no but you may have actually
been infected by me too
oh dude i don't give a [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] dude
i really don't get what is so
complicated to understand
about how this virus works but even if
you don't give a [ __ ] how can you not
tell homeboy all your guests and people
in your studio
yeah i mean there's four people in that
shot that we're looking at
should put it there look oh yeah there's
like they have a camera operator too
well logan is basically talking right at
him if he has kovid this guy has coveted
literally breathing in his [ __ ] face
everyone in the room
yeah probably most likely right
this virus is super contagious
yeah i mean it's most contagious when
you're indoors and breathing and talking
and stuff like that
oh my god we gotta let this guy know he
has covet
what's his name let's get this guy let's
let him know
america uh oh he just saw
he just uploaded a new video four months
ago america
is racist yeah and they're also [ __ ]
spreading covet so
pick a lane dude are you whoa i mean
like
i wish so netflix oh this is the guy
from
i know who this guy is the guy from that
dumbass reality show
what's his name the english dude love
island is that what it's called
sin island whatever the [ __ ] that yeah
anybody help me out here oh
wasn't that well he's got covered now
isn't that a great show
yeah we enjoyed it oh yeah
just some trashy reality show so now
jake paul
and um logan have come together to
create a
fight stranded in like a month
18 days right now we wanted to make like
a big
damn this shit's crazy
this is crazy
you know like i'm we're going through so
much effort to be safe we moved our
production home
we're doing all this we've got all these
guys
i mean everything has
had to change the way we work on teddy
fresh is completely different now and
it's
it's it makes it way more difficult to
get things done
how are we ever going to move past when
you've got these bozos
going out on weekends they've been
exposed they're just you can't
what the [ __ ] is going on but also this
requires everyone to be understanding am
i the only one that cares about the
rules
big lebowski over the line thank you
yeah we all need to chip in these guys
are not willing to change
i cannot believe that they don't care
that much they
like your action could end up with
someone dying
yeah it's that simple oh yeah yeah
100 percent not care i don't understand
that
they both independently of each other
said i don't give a [ __ ]
they're like hey bro i was hanging out
with you and i just got my
diagnosis i have covet i don't really
[ __ ] care bro
they both said that anyway so let's see
what jake and logan have been up to who
are both
probably have covered um
so nikita dragon a beauty influencer
through a party
uh for tick tocker
in the video other influences and social
media people are shown partying in a
space
enclosed space with crowds of people
standing close to each other not wearing
masks no social distancing
that's putting it mildly it's like a
[ __ ] orgy in this house
i was like dude these kids are crazy
you're gonna have to edit some of this
oh by the way they're sharing
the cheering joy she's not showing
sharing joints
well she's you'd think she smoked that
whole thing by herself that looks like a
cigar
you think she you think she smoked that
whole cigar by herself
and may i also ask separately who smokes
that cigar
indoors i mean that's crazy do you know
how much that's just
kinks people who like to have fun bro
you're gonna [ __ ] hot box a room with
cigars
oh yeah sounds like a dream to me dude
that's the craziest [ __ ] i ever heard
anyway i bet you someone else caught
that
well we don't need to speculate
so this is the party tana's there
it's so awesome dude i mean it's a
full-on party
everyone is it's packed they're all in
there
sweating and i mean this is a public
health nightmare
it's crazy and there were so many
influencers there
tick tockers just a bunch of young kids
who quote don't give a [ __ ]
but they all have big um following
well tana was a a bunch of them so
you're gonna have to censor this because
it's
so here's a little highlight reel from
the birthday party
uh these kids are crazy bro
looks like a lot of fun so it looks to
me like a covid party
if you go to her page she has a lot of
followers
uh yeah it's a nikita dragon dude
7.8 million get it how are you going to
put
that kind of message out there to 7.8
million
let's see if there's any comments of
people being like oh dude there are a
lot
read the room we are in a pandemic oh
that's the top comment yeah
yeah i mean obviously but like what's
even better is knowing that there's
people there who have
been in contact with kobe yeah and it's
all and they're like [ __ ] it
for us available to watch
so um
that's pretty much it i didn't know
logan said i don't give a [ __ ] i mean
that's so epic
i love it dude yeah i guess never mind
on the whole uh
yeah i mean zach you had confessed to us
that you are a logan paul
fan he's a stan even he's a massive fan
what dan i was just giving you [ __ ]
you're not that good
no i'm not a massive fan i i think the
dude has definitely changed his
content for the better i'm not
necessarily talking about oh he's got
porn stars on
like he just seems a lot more calmed
down
than jake and what do you think about
him saying that he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about having covered
oh it's [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] he lost i
lost a bunch of respect for him
yeah you know what i'm gonna have to
agree like uh he was making he was
seeming
like he turned a corner but that call
kind of he seemed very douchey in that
call he's like oh bro why are you
calling me it was kind of the vibe he's
like
right he's like listen dude what are you
telling me for okay well i don't give a
[ __ ]
all right see ya and he got off the
phone real fast too like yeah why is
tanner calling me
little bitch-ass tanner
i didn't say it he did it tanner you did
the right thing if you're listening
which i'm sure you're not
yeah especially filming it and putting
it online for us all so you know
yeah exposing these [ __ ] yeah
i don't know what to say it's just it
it's kind of
really shitty to to have to see all that
because
everyone has to take it so seriously
and single-handedly these kids are gonna
cause an outbreak here in l.a there
already is an outbreak in l.a
well they're gonna just make it worse
california is really hard hit
and that party you know like all these
kids partying like
there's gonna be people who are gonna
die as a result of that yeah
like just straight up and did you see
the um
we had sent it in the chat earlier this
morning but the tweet from
elijah daniel right that's kind of uh
oh where is it i've got in front of me
if you want me to just read it
he just said warning a lot of
influencers have been confirming to me
that they've tested positive for coven
19 after influencer parties like a lot
they aren't saying anything and they
aren't warning people that they came
into contact with after
if you attended get tested you all
caused an outbreak
thanks i'm telling you everybody at that
party
has coveted everybody who's going on
logan's podcast
is in danger everybody who's hanging out
with these two bozos
who have now these two guys together
have combined
done thing this is way [ __ ] worse
than anything they've ever done
they're knowingly spreading covet and
it's insane
james charles was also at the party and
he vlogged it
why don't i have that he also at least
he
seems to take it a little bit more
serious since people called him out for
it he added like a
a note in the video when the part comes
where you saw the party before
it now has a black screen with a message
like sorry that
i was so irresponsible kind of message
okay that's good so at least you know
would be responsible staying in his
[ __ ] house
with that fine ass the whole video is
vlogging him
going around they went for a dinner
first with friends
and then they go to the party got in an
uber
like so many interactions with people
these paul brothers this might be a new
love for the two of them
because you think like logan's redeemed
himself it wouldn't have been so cool if
he called him he's like oh
dude that's such a bummer i gotta i
gotta go get tested
i'm really worried no what he said is so
jake got off the phone
he was worried enough to call his mom my
mom called me
they're worried enough but independently
we both said [ __ ] it
we're not going to change anything in
our life we're not willing to sacrifice
anything in our life to help end this
pandemic because
we're rich we're successful we'll be
sick it's like
a total inability to think outside
yourself
i think there's a widespread sort of mis
i mean it's not a total misconception
but the
the whole thing about um you know
younger people not getting hit that hard
by
it uh well they don't die from it they
can get very sick they can
though they can but it's very rare right
it's a low risk so
they probably just have the attitude
that nothing really bad is going to
happen to me
but that's what i can't understand what
is so hard to understand
like how many times do people need to
explain that that's not it
that's not how you can't look at it like
that and then you give it to other
people that maybe
it is a big deal yeah exactly all these
people
some of them i'm sure still lives with
their parents right those who are young
kids they're gonna go back home give it
to their parents
yeah like well actually they think the
thing is that such a new virus
what they're learning is that there
could be dire
long-term uh ramifications from having
this virus
even in young people you do not want
this thing
if you get it like because it's so new
we don't know but a lot of people who
suffered from it even in young age
have long-term effects months down the
line
from either respiratory
stomach problems yeah like i mean
there's certain
viruses that can increase your your
chances of getting cancer like cervical
cancer and stuff you can get certain
viruses that actually really
have dire consequences this might be one
of them we don't know enough about the
virus yet
this that's [ __ ] bro damn shame on
logan paul
and jake i expected of jake but i
thought logan had turned up
corner yeah but he sounds like the same
old douchebag
in that phone call yeah he really
disappointed me
i'm sorry sorry zack yeah i feel bad for
you we'll unsubscribe to him
whoa wait i thought you said hang on
you said you watched his videos but you
didn't subscribe
that was a liar oh
[ __ ] you watch all of his uploads do you
watch his podcast
no [ __ ] no i hate that mic dude you hate
mike that's why whoa he's
easy podcast right now we'll watch and
listen to is the h3 podcast
do you own any maverick merch [ __ ] no
are are you a maverick do you consider
yourself a maverick no
okay are you jealous that mike is
uh sleeping with lana rhodes absolutely
not
would you have sex with a porn star um
[Music]
no no not ah sounds like
yeah it sounds like i mean there's
there's nothing wrong with heaven
there's nothing wrong with it
you know i've seen some alana roads work
obviously
she's in everything to be honest but
like she does the craziest [ __ ] like
she'll take like
a 20-yard dick that's like 10 feet wide
20 20
no i'm just saying like she she'll take
like she does like the craziest porn you
can imagine
with like dicks like tons of dicks in
every hole and all that
and i don't i just don't understand how
can you please a woman like that
after that she's actively taking like 20
dicks in her vag
that same day well i have a feeling that
that's not she's not actually being
pleased in that scene
yeah no no no no no how does g how does
mike please her
oh yeah but not not because not no but i
mean literally like
like the vag has got to be slick pretty
straight oh you think red
i know that the vet i know like the
vagina like goes down in size like
eventually but like if you got railed by
like
20 massive dicks that same day i feel
like his dick is just like slipping
through a
uh a plastic bag i think that's probably
a really
dumb dumb way to look at it you think
that your vagina would feel totally
normal
yeah and she probably doesn't
necessarily want
that in her personal no no i'm not
saying that i'm just saying that i feel
like well to satisfy her he doesn't
necessarily need to have
i'm not i'm not sorry i'm not i'm i'm
not saying anything about
she actually wanting that in her private
life i'm just saying that her v
her probably so enlarged from that kind
of activity
on that day on the day of or maybe a few
days after
that i think the idea of the the
stretched out vagina is a bit
exaggerated yeah i feel like no no
but like dude she's taking like three
dicks in her vagina
ian it's not like oh she was slept with
a bigger
dick dude it's not like at the same time
in your mouth and now you have a big
mouth like it comes back
i mean i had a baby yeah i know but like
yeah but like and if okay and right and
if we had sex on that same day
um it probably would be bigger
hmm well the whole body kind of shifts i
mean i'm curious yeah and
your body shifts when you get no
i mean i think it's an interesting
conversation to have and i'm and i'm
happy to hear your perspective on it
i think as the only person who has a
vagina on the show
yeah uh to me that sounds stupid so you
think
it might depend on the specific girl and
what they're into but
i don't think i'm not talking about her
pleasure she probably just likes being
with that dude
d i don't know what his stick size is
but like that's probably what she
there's nothing wrong with that i'm just
saying
physiologically if you got railed by
like 3
12 inchers at the same time like this
in your vag boom if you came home that
night and slept with me
my dick wouldn't touch even the outer
edge of your vagina
um so i i still disagree with that but i
feel like she
also probably just doesn't even want to
do it on that day so it doesn't even
yeah she's probably
not really like it's like you coming
back from a really long day of work or
something
she's prolific she [ __ ] a lot like she
does a lot of porno
like yeah maybe but also i think you
should
watch out for this message that you
might be sending because
what are you trying to say oh
okay let me say it in a term enjoy her
work right
i mean yeah yeah what type of work hold
on hold on
i'm not trying to say anything i'm
really i'm not really trying to say
anything
let's say it put it this way let's say
me and you are in a happy a consenting
monogamous relationship and you do porn
on the set that day you have sex with
the dude with the biggest penis you've
ever seen in your life
yeah i mean i already understood them
and then you come home
yeah i'm not even talking about like but
so like but you're saying she wouldn't
want to have sex on that same day i
disagree why not
because she does it every day i doubt
she does it every day
yeah i could be wrong there you could be
wrong in many places it certainly could
be of course
i certainly could maybe they block shoot
it you know i feel like the whole
this whole idea is uh very like
men in a way kind of like down
looking down on porn stars because it's
like
i would never want to [ __ ] no because
her vagina is hold on huge
okay that's fine let me let me say it
more clearly
i would have no problem say it any more
clearly no no no no very clear no
because i feel like you're
misunderstanding when you say that
well let me clarify i have no problem i
would have no problem dating a porn star
i think it's legitimate work i
understand but hold on hold on
if she calls the idea
i think people that inserted that
negative
let me let me finish
if she comes home
and she hasn't had sex with like a like
a like a
king dong in a week then her vag
probably
feels i don't know how long it takes to
bounce back i literally just looked it
up
to confirm yeah after relaxing during
sex vaginal muscle tissue naturally
contracts and then tightens again
intercourse does not permanently stretch
the vagina
this process loosening during arousal
and tightening afterward
happens no matter how often the woman
has sex what
i'm not saying permanently i'm saying
the same day
you need like some time for it to bounce
back
okay why are you talking about soreness
like they would be sore
[Music]
i'm on my own you're right i'm on an
island
because
a week later it's probably not totally
back to normal
did you know what i said a week he just
said right after
okay okay let's let's get more micro
you're in a room
why why don't we stop don't worry more
micro
you're in a room there's two dudes in a
room one has a 12-incher
and one's got just a normal deck the
dude with the 12-incher
slams it and then you go in right
afterwards
you're probably not going to get the
same sensation that you would get if the
the 12-incher didn't go first right over
you've changed we're done
we've changed the whole parameter yeah
you changed that well hold on
i'm trying to start small and expand no
it's not even
you said you're trying to start small
and expand just like a vagina
okay but ian do would you have the same
sensation immediately after a 12
incher who knows first you said coming
home from work
stop follow my yes answer the question
you're being sad no not no not
immediately after okay so then that
presumes
to and it's completely different
interrupting me
i know that presumes that there is some
time that it takes to
to go back to normal so are we talking
about an hour
are we talking about a day do you want
to conduct a research
we don't know my only simply being that
how do you follow up it's hard to follow
up and act like that
the article i'm reading was saying that
there's a natural
um uh
contracting during intercourse this
process
loosening during arousal and then
tightening right afterwards
so yeah that sounds accurate that sounds
like 30 minutes later you're back to
normal
but i think there'd still be some
soreness though right i'm not
well hold on but he's not talking about
these are talking about
normal circumstance you have not seen
blackto.com
i'm just [ __ ] around you you're
getting so
you're not liking this combo but i feel
like it's entertaining
you know why i don't like it because i
see too much lately um
like people like kim star who will make
all these stupid jokes at the expense of
really nice girls that um it's just like
angry men child
uh like they they hide their intention
and they're like oh i'm just making a
joke but uh no you're actually just
making
fun of a i don't know it's like high
school drama
either way um i just i wanna i guess it
makes me
think twice about what kind of message
we put out there even if we're just
making a joke
i don't for the record i don't think
being a porn star permanently
increases the size of your vagina but
i'm just talking about the immediate
aftermath
but either way i feel like just going
there is kind of supporting that
way of looking down at porn stars when i
think a lot of men
feel very comfortable doing that while
they enjoy the porn very much so
you kind of need to pick a side i don't
and i'm not talking about you
i'm not talking to you but i don't want
to be part of that conversation
i agree and i i i don't want to either i
know what you're talking about i'm
literally just talking about
following a 12 inch dong an hour a
couple that same night
well then let's talk about why are you
following a 12-inch dong
because porn star okay well maybe she
but who said that's even a scenario you
know
like right i don't know what so your
joke is not really
i think it was an interesting debate and
clearly we need some scientific research
to follow it up
because i think you might find
dude you got to see some of the [ __ ]
she's done i'm just telling you she's
not like a normal porn star she like
goes all out she and and i mean that is
committed to her craft can you confirm
that zach
no i can't
why not what do you mean i've been i
haven't seen any of her
her films to be completely honest with
you i haven't seen i don't even know
what she looks like she's the number one
most popular
i know the name but
and they have like a models like most
popular she's number one
i find it hard to believe that zach of
all people has
well maybe that that's not what i'm into
yeah what are you into
i'm into my girlfriend oh please turn
his mind
okay shut up sorry
you can still watch porn yeah it's fine
honestly when i was like really i was
much younger i watched a lot of porn and
it just kind of bores me now
i've gone through phases like that but
ultimately
i mean yeah ultimately when you're like
single and really [ __ ]
like rock bottom loneliness you can
watch too much porn and you're like oh
dude
it just i i don't know it just it
doesn't
it's not my thing anymore well
anyway i'm just look uh
god bless mike i mean you know she's
she's a beautiful girl and
i think she's really talented she's good
at her job clearly
and she's smart and i think that it's a
she's a smart business lady and
she's really successful and i certainly
don't don't
mean anything by it you know i think
she's perfectly dateable i mean my god
but you can see how um those kind of
conversations
well there's a difference i think bad
intentions i think what you're thinking
of is when someone goes like i would
have never dated porn star because their
vaginas are huge
but that's not what i'm saying yeah but
you might appeal to those people
okay okay so let me just be very clear i
don't think porn stars have
giant vaginas but i just know that i
know her i'm familiar with her body of
work
and the type of content she makes and
knowing that about her
because she goes to the exchange she's
like she's a born olympian
it's interesting what it's like to date
her yeah exactly
interesting now i want to hear about
that for mike now all of a sudden i want
mike on
the show well she she doesn't do uh porn
anymore she only does like only fan solo
what
so there you go then because you know um
there you go so then that that answers
my question and i and i don't think that
she has like
a residual giant vagina from doing porn
does she not [ __ ] dudes on her only fans
just solo stuff
i i that's what i'm that's what i've
heard yes
you've heard that i thought you didn't
weren't aware of her
i mean i know who she is he's watched
the vlogs he's a he's a maverick dude
he's right
you're judas
all right so did we uh cover did we uh
reach common ground here on the whole uh
giant vagina
first and the collapsing there is no
giant vagina that's the conversation
well when she's having sex it gets big
okay well now we're down to when it is
it shrinks
over time okay yeah
well i can that's just how the vagina
functions i can testify
i mean like you said you gave birth and
i i will say on record that
it feels the same as it did before
so i mean that this there's no penis as
big as theodore's head
you know i saw that [ __ ] so
like yeah
you know god bless the vagina i feel
like i'm seeing
so much negativity lately that i might
be
turning a little bit woke or like
going in that direction more and maybe
it's annoying but
i just don't want to have anything to do
with like all this like so much
negativity that i see everywhere lately
and so it may hurt some of your jokes
but i'm a little sensitive lately that's
okay
you have every right to be there's too
much negativity out there i
actually just can't like stand seeing
all this [ __ ]
but i'm glad you said something because
i want to
i don't first of all want to come off
that way and i think we had a good uh
conversation about it i think we covered
a lot of ground
so it was good but you want to talk
about keemstar
raiding pokemane because that's next on
my agenda it kind of fits perfectly
sure keemstar has been obsessed lately
with
um demeaning women specifically pokemon
is a beaut i mean she's
obviously pokemon excuse me pokemon is
obviously extremely beautiful
twitch streamer one of the most popular
[Music]
she has a large fan base she's a gamer
and this is her i mean
people say she has a lot of simps
whatever that means but
i guess they said about any beautiful uh
internet personality
but she um so he called her ugly
erated her unprompted for some reason he
said she's a two out of ten
and that by the way that's not in a
vacuum no insane
that's not in a vacuum them comes off of
keemstar calling ila a horse
comes off him calling starkiller's wife
a witch
and um he just straight up
out of the blue said pokemane is a two
out of ten
which is ironic considering uh you know
i
i i don't like to address people's looks
but i feel like since he
has publicly made it a point of
raiding women's appearance then i can
say that
he is
keemstar is like it's really crazy
because he brings you down
to his level like he makes you want to
insult him back you know like look at
yourself
but it's just it's just such a
shitty thing to do for him why
why even go there well and then he he
gets
so like the result of this is now people
are like
there's a picture of pokeman without
makeup that not everyone's posting and
being like look at her she's lying to us
she still looks perfectly fine yeah all
these people are
are uh basically saying is that they've
never had a girl sleep over before
i mean she looks she looks beautiful she
looks literally
the same it's like oh dude you've oh
you're literally a virgin
you've never seen a girl without makeup
like wow
right the fact that you're upset about
her not wearing
about her without makeup by the way just
means that you
literally are so virgin you've never had
a girl care about you enough
to sleep over and take makeup off her
face
and then if you by the way if she was
just on the internet like this without
makeup you would call her
like ugly and [ __ ] plain and [ __ ]
so there you go like she literally
doesn't look that different
and anyway now now anyway she's she's
the subject of all this like red pill to
insult energy now
spearheaded from keemstar and what's
really sad is that those tweets do
really well for him too
[Music]
yeah uh
here's some some follow-ups because
people were getting angry at
keemstar for being a oh yeah he blocked
me here i've got a backup
i've anticipated this
y'all remember when keemstar blocked me
pretty epic
[ __ ] hey don't say that we're trying to
have a civil conversation here about it
j just a quick side note about that
sound bite uh
dan and i were testing it and those two
there's
two of them there's garbage and then
this
one it actually makes a fifth which is a
power chord it's a perfect fit
he's got a very musical uh oh you gotta
make a song out of that garbage garbage
garbage garbage garbage garbage like
because you you'll
you'll hear it it garbage you're
like powerpoint yeah we gotta get that
to shmo yoho
and get him to make a a power ballad
h3 is [ __ ] innocent
garbage garbage here
man there's some straight up weirdos on
there
strip weirdos mad people who man people
who don't just bully people randomly on
the internet are weirdos
weirdos weirdos oh you grabbed that good
zach
weirdos garbage weirdos
over the last 24 hours i've been getting
this criticism of people saying that i'm
a bad role model
that uh i'm setting a bad example for my
followers and
all this type of stuff and i understand
that
for many people like in gaming
entertainment and
online entertainment they
view themselves as role models they view
themselves as
out there showing people how to be the
right thing and do the right thing and
set a good example
i understand i am the opposite that's
totally fine he's like i set out to be
the opposite of that but this isn't
church
okay this is online entertainment right
my suggests mean that you don't have a
con like he's like this isn't church
okay
so yes i don't have a conscience and i
literally just tried to ruin people's
life
in fact i get semi-hard entertainment i
could say my heart
knowing that someone i've made fun of is
suicidal
in fact there's been about four of them
who have admitted to being suicidal
because of the attention i give them
that makes me rock hard that's the only
thing that makes me hard in fact viagra
doesn't work anymore
the only thing that gets me hard is when
people say they're suicidal because of
me
weirdos that's the only time
i can get it up for long enough to give
it to my girlfriend
who by the way who by the way is a two
out of ten
and i tell her that every day i don't
know why she doesn't like me
i like to know who keemstar thinks is
attractive you know
whoever that woman is who does keemstar
actually find attractive you know
his beard he probably comes in his beard
his right hand yeah oh baby you're the
only one for me
comes in his beard oh yeah that's how i
get up extra pointy
the [ __ ] i want those kids when they go
to twitter who are bored i want them to
go to my tweet
uh feed excuse me and find something
entertaining
to to to to read or to talk about or
to have an opinion right that is my
objective as a person in
online entertainment your objective can
go out there to be
you know the the
like i i guarantee he's not amused at
all he's just trying to
put up a front like he doesn't care uh
teachers can
be you know the pope or whatever you're
trying to be you know i don't want to be
the
guy by not making people suicidal that
uh you're putting out there that's all
fine
but you live in a box i don't live in
your [ __ ] box i live in my own
goddamn world
my own world is pretty dope so go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] my
by the way that's the biggest cry for
help ever my world is pretty dope
so that's his response to the criticism
there's actually been a whole slew of
tweets here let's have a look the thing
is that
you don't choose to um
to take responsibility
when once you once you have a big
following
it just comes with it it's not really up
to your
decision like like all these influencers
going to a party during a pandemic
they can't be putting out that message
once you have
like that one girl had almost eight
million followers
they they think whatever she does is
cool they
they you know their kids who are
following her because whatever she's
doing they love and they think it's cool
if they see her going to parties that's
going to affect them
well the truth is they have to come to
terms with that some people have
a level of maturity to be like uh i feel
bad about that and i shouldn't do it
and some people truly don't give a [ __ ]
like the logan brothers and keemstar
they say i just i literally don't care
yeah and that's the difference between
some people another nobody's trying to
be the pope it's just
if you're more mature human being that
actually cares about
the message you're putting out into the
world then you don't do certain things
like [ __ ] calling women ugly
on twitter you know
that's just that i mean keemstar's world
is [ __ ]
dope can you hear him
my world is [ __ ] dope
so there you have that um
don't you find it strange that three
women like all within like the past
couple weeks he's called ug
he's just gone and called ugly you're a
horse yeah
you're objectively beautiful
starkiller's wife objectively beautiful
as a witch
and pokemon objectively beautiful as a
two out of ten
yeah it's like bro you you hate your mom
or something dude
i guarantee you keemstar hates his mom
100 1000 he feels unloved by
females there's an analysis there for
sure
if you ask me in my own clinical
opinion i think keemstar feel unloved by
his own mother and so
he i think he has a deep deep
issue loving women because he distrusts
them i think he
going on a limb here but i think he was
probably abandoned by his mother in some
way
and so he feels like all women are
worthless
and untrustable it probably stems
something deep psychological issue like
that i mean he's
such a complicated phenomena he will
need
a lot of analyzing oh yeah of what
happened there oh yeah
you know how you have like fbi tapes
like 50 fbi tapes of like
studying these crazy [ __ ] people that
have done like heinous crimes
that's what you need to get to the heart
of keemstar someone's sitting there with
a cigarette and on tape and be like
you hear this [ __ ] okay continue
you know chain smoking anyway
uh keemstar posted he says he's sorry
he posts a meme yada yada yada anything
else interesting
not really oh he just there's been a lot
of tweets but this is him that
enlightened chad no you can't rape my
queen two out of ten
ha ha pokey two out of ten
funny because he usually looks like the
one on the left
he's such a [ __ ] he is [ __ ] you
spelled it out
the enlightened chad
the us army is trying the us
army i always found recruitment in the
army so creepy like how they show up to
high schools and [ __ ] and they try to
trick people not trick but they try to
sell their services and stuff but what
they are doing on twitch
i do find quite creepy uh the army and
navy
started an esports channel where members
of the military live streamed themselves
playing video games like call of duty
fortnite etc
and the controversy began when people
okay so it goes back a little bit
but what they were doing is they were
doing a giveaway like they were giving
away
xbox or something and then when someone
clicked the link it would take them to
the [ __ ]
recruitment page
i mean so epic i mean how is that
comparable
committing your life to the us army for
a chance to win at xbox
that is the most dystopian [ __ ] i have
ever seen so it didn't it didn't make
you sign up right there and then but it
like
it was a sign up to start the process of
you know giving them
all your info so they but they say
they're like hey this is a giveaway page
and then you sign up to the [ __ ] army
dude
that's funny that's not funny that's
just
crazy i think i put the link to
what that page looks like uh oh for real
yeah
i can see like once you click on the
content go army.com
be all you can be in and on mark grave
sorry so as you can see there's no
information about a contest or anything
it's just
yeah this is just straight up sign out
to sign up to be in the army
right name birthday email phone number
zip
which path are you interested in
full-time
weekend i just want the xbox roll
where's the button for xbox
it wasn't even an xbox it's just a
controller you don't even get a full
xbox for
damn how much money those [ __ ]
get they can't even go to xbox just a
controller
that's crazy [ __ ]
why even go that far just give out a
goddamn
free trial of a navy game
oh yeah they're giving out an xbox elite
series 2 controller
so here's what your life is worth to the
army
let's have a look at what the elite
series xbox 2 controller is
guys this is it
this is it the big
giveaway how much is this thing
i think it's like 200 bucks wow it's a
nice controller to be fair
that's a lot of controller yeah that is
a lot of controller damn
the army damn they got a crazy budget on
this giveaway
200 [ __ ]
so um super creepy
and eventually twitch i guess
shut down the whole [ __ ] thing cool
well twitch was like yo you can't do
this this is misleading you can't tell
people you're giving away
a good caller and it goes to a
recruitment page totally misleading
and they said um let's see each giveaway
has its own url
and marketing activity they said that
connects the registrant to a specific
giveaway
an eligible winner is selected at random
and the prize is given out twitch asked
our team to remove the giveaway for lack
of transparency
and they did so you do have to sign up
for that [ __ ] to win
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you army
i give away i give away a thousand
dollars a day
some for nothing tells me they don't
even give any not even one controller so
they claim
here specifically they say uh the
spokesman
said the giveaways were legit and the
army has given away 10
controllers a gaming station
and a chair
just over the past year why what's the
us army's budget again
oh my goodness it's some measured in
trillions
u.s army budget is 721.5 billion oh okay
just just shy of a trillion a couple
billy
apparently my giveaway budget is way
higher than the armies and i don't even
[ __ ] ask you to give your life a wave
i don't even ask you to die in service
of me
you know but did you know that uh
like in the nfl
they always like salute the flag and
have uh plane flyovers and [ __ ]
during sports events those are actually
paid sponsors by
the army to get recruitment and make the
army seem so cool
so cool the army
the whole idea of um having like
commercials for going to the army is so
weird to me because in israel it's just
mandatory so yeah israel they're like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're coming
so i guess that is good in a way
but i don't i can't think of a good war
we've been involved in since like
you know vietnam no i'm just kidding
world war ii
so it's hard to like arguably no war is
good
but yeah but i get your point like a
noble war i guess
one might call it you know
um i mean the army does a lot of good
stuff though
they they do a lot of community stuff
like the engineers
they do a lot of nation building in a
good way not always bad but
any anyway whatever you think about the
army obviously it's necessary i'm not
saying disband the army i love the army
brave soldiers brave
soldiers the people who serve in the
army are our heroes i think the
institution of the army is is
is corrupt in places
but the the people who serve are are
heroic
the point being is that you're worth
more than a god
damn xbox controller can we move are we
done with this topic
uh that's it and then we're gonna have
shoe nice call in does anyone want to
speak on the topic of the us army being
banned on twitch before we move on
uh i just like the there was um
prior to them i don't think they got
banned i think they voluntarily uh
closed it down because of all the crap
they were getting but yeah there was
another angle to this too where
people were spamming their chat with um
because part of it was like you have all
these service members streaming
and you can ask them questions about
what life in the military is like
and so people were asking them like hey
what's your favorite war crime
yeah here's a clip of that i guess they
were starting to
you know they didn't expect to get
trolled on twitch but obviously that's
the whole yeah i think here's a guy
playing uh
uh warzone there's
i saw there's only like 20 people in the
[ __ ] chat
here 22 people what are they doing
22 people and so someone starts asking
homie
every post that i do from now on is
going to say oo in it just some flex
i like it yo y'all gonna go talk all
that crap
to my angel on the east coast what's
your favorite us
so they blocked warcraft internet people
are spamming it
little gremlin you little gremlins i saw
what's your favorite
us war crimes spelled
i won't stand for that i'm bigger than
you
i gotta tell you signing up for the army
i'll sign up for the army if my job is
to stream on twitch
wait back door front door yeah back door
oh they got oh then he posted the
wikipedia
link too a list of us
dared for sale what's up man oh cool
nice
have a nice time getting banned my dude
by the way i will say that obviously i i
understand why they're banning a lot
they're not sitting there trying to get
everyone's spamming what's your favorite
us work
well here's where it gets tricky is
normally obviously
you can ban whoever you want for
whatever reason in
your channel but because it's actually
the official u.s military and that's
part of
federal government you can't necessarily
i mean the first amendment that that
this is an actual free speech issue
unlike
that's really interesting yeah yeah so
they they were getting threatened to be
sued
for violating first amendment rights
because it that is literally
the government blocking speech yeah it's
the same with donald trump he was
blocking people on twitter and a judge
right he can't you can't do that people
right yeah although as far as i'm aware
he has not unblocked anybody still
maybe he did i don't know yeah maybe he
did but that's but anyway
i think that's probably why they pulled
the plug they're like oh this is getting
weight too yeah it just seemed like
it caught them a huge headache i mean 20
views
right i mean they're like dude we've
given away 10 controllers
one chair and one gaming pc and we've
only gotten like
five sign ups well i was reading
evidently they're they're desperate uh
apparently recruitment has um
has gone just down and down and down
over the last you know what a couple
decades and
now with covet it's it's like completely
dried up they're not getting anybody
signing up you know what i may suggest
to the army
uh compensating people better that might
get more recruitment
instead of trying to trick them into
winning a 200
uh controller or perhaps not perpetually
being
at war so that when you sign up you're
pretty much
know that you're going to be shipped to
afghanistan or something
uh well we'll take it one thing at a
time here dan
true if the you if the if the army was
more
yeah i don't think they had any problem
with recruitment in the 90s when we were
at peace
yeah i wouldn't i yeah i wouldn't want
to sign up and get shipped off to
[ __ ]
afghanistan [ __ ] that you know
all these guys come back with ptsd so
many vets
committing suicide living on the streets
if you want more recruitments
treat your vets better damn
there's a reason why people don't want
to join the army because it [ __ ]
sucks because
vets get treated like [ __ ] you don't get
compensated
it's dangerous and uh
that's pretty much it you know it's good
enough you should hire me
let's close down that twitch chat and
just
pay people a little bit more and give
them [ __ ] health insurance
and therapy
right evil right thank you
speaking of vets we have searching for a
button we have one we're about to uh
speak to you right shoe nice is a vet so
we celebrate shoe nice
shoe nice is moving to los angeles you
look you want me to wait for the sound
by deal
no i couldn't find anything you weren't
going to cricket me because i was
celebrating the vets how dare you no i
wasn't going to cricket
i was looking for something new i guess
um i didn't find something that i wanted
to use
if you took a 12 incher ila you would be
petite in within
seconds
um garbage
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a i don't like it
[Laughter]
well so uh shoenice is on the phone
he's moving to los angeles or not los
angeles he's living in a baker field
he's moving to california in a couple of
weeks and we're very excited to
welcome shoenice into our state so we
thought it'd be fun to get on a call
with him
see how he's doing and check in with our
boys so with that being said let's check
in
with the shoe
nice with us today
of course is the legendary shoe nice
eater of tampons destroyer of
10-pound reese's uh bars
and uh marge simpson also
moonlight says marge simpson nice cops
hi hobie hey homie
shut up
sorry who's your who's your favorite
alternate personality you've got the
joker you've got marge simpson who
speaks to you
more um i'm on the level with probably
rocky balboa
oh you do i didn't you did that
knowledge of life do you do a rocky
balboa impression
what about the congratulations for
getting your check mark baxter nice
you're the only youtube channel that
ever got a check mark back in a second
chance on youtube after losing their
main channel
uh-huh oh congratulations thank you
that's a big uh
big victory for the shoei congrats
appreciate it guys appreciate it feels
good man to be back because that check
mark just puts you above 100 other
million people you know bro
how do you feel about people who don't
have check marks
they should apply for them because i
tell them all the time like airsoft
fatty
badlands chugs he didn't even know about
it so every time i see somebody with a
hundred thousand
or more subscribers i say yo go apply
for your check mark just google it
yeah i okay great i mean that's really
good advice
sure before we get into the main story
here of having you on today
i do have a little bit of a beef with
you that i'd like to squash here today
i feel like you're an agent of chaos you
came on our show
and um right you tossed us into disarray
you claimed that goku naru
you took down kokunaro's video then you
went on twitter
and you started saying that you were
lying and then you were i mean
shu you are a true agent of chaos can i
trust you at all with anything you say
here today
yeah to be honest with you i was hoping
we weren't going to jump back there but
we might as well get that as well as
well i've got to address and again
in the end i didn't like the fact of my
son and you getting shot so every time i
seen it
i did report it we're going back
we're going back we're stepping back now
what's going on
so when you talk to me it's one story
when you talk over 90 days i'm sober 90
days bro i'm gonna say i'm i'm a
businessman now
i'm a bit i got tired what is the truth
what is the truth true nice
that's all i want i'm looking forward
i'm looking you guys right in the eye
look not even blinking
you never blink i reported that video as
many times as i could
with my channel and alternate ones how
many come at me
how many times do you think it's still
on youtube it's still on youtube with
hundreds of thousands of views
right that's my yeah totally how many
times
i guess it's just you know it's more
publicity for us bro
right hell yeah we win every time right
chill
yeah and if we get together it's going
to be nothing but 2 million views
12 hours after an upload absolutely
should we make a video i'm sorry
should we make a video executing goku
naru together no i'm just kidding
obviously not
but um i don't see i don't waste my
video uploads on all that like
but you know drama skirt and all that he
just got his ads back he's happy he
played it off but if he didn't get his
partnership back he'd be crying the
blues bro
sorry for that side note that's okay
okay wait i thought didn't you just say
you didn't have a laptop
no i do but i can't i can't do when
chromebook
see what it says on there drama alert oh
my god
is a b drama
it's a [ __ ] now can you
guess how if you reported it from your
main channel
and all of your alternate channels can
you guess how many times did you report
goku narrows video
oh i didn't have all the ones they took
away but they just gave them back to me
um
probably just my ip2 my this channel and
another one
but i also sent in a snapchat family of
about 15
000 people to report it to that's what i
do when i don't like somebody
wow what is your snapchat family you're
just your followers on snapchat
you said i dropped them like nothing
dude when i got a hundred thousand
subscribers
i literally went on four snapchats i
quick added five thousand people
i'm the king of spam there'll be a movie
about me and i
literally just had them there was high
schools
sharing in the auditorium shoe nice shoe
nice
cause they thought i was gonna come
visit the school and there was like
30 of them bro wow
and so they all reported goku nar's
video
tell these people man they're like how'd
you get so famous how do you do where do
you get the view
views aren't going to come knocking on
your door bro no
i mean literally you got to go out and
find them back in the day a vacuum
cleaner guy or anybody with a business
knocking on doors
now it's soliciting to have a hundred
thousand people at your fingertips
and show them that you slam bottles of
olive oil
in 13 seconds they're gonna stay
if you're just a piano guy playing the
guitar
skateboarding there's a million of them
out there bro
we bring shoe nice in with h3h3
i don't even remember that one show what
was it david letterman
you guys would be in the studio and i'd
be out on the streets
and you guys would just be doing pranks
on me or whatever
a couple arrests here and there we'll be
famous and we'll be real
not fake like roman atwood and vitali
hold on a second bro
go ahead what's in that mug
oh he's gone what happened
hey eat the imagineering into your eyes
every morning
is that pretty creepy yeah i wouldn't
like that i definitely wouldn't like
that
you're not gonna get a jack just sitting
there
sorry i do notice shoei that uh
on twitter you follow so many people
that
twitter disables your ability to follow
more people for like 24 hours
i've never heard of that before so you
really are a follower
maniac rob there's there's things
nobody's ever seen before i've had 15
facebook i have a lady in twitter she
just i got lucky this time with 4 000
followers
this lady just waits for shoe nice to
come back on twitter and bang
she i mean howie mandel blocked me i
mean i was just ripping on the dude i'm
like dude i mean for real
um america's got town has no town
including the judges
and he blocks and records me
[Music]
yeah you don't want howie mandela as an
enemy
the kardashians blocked me uh twice
and that was back on my main channel
that's pretty cool to say that you know
what i mean
for a lawyer to come in and say stop
saying kim k is with jj
smells like hey and maymay a lawyer told
me that
oh so you're moving to bakersfield
that's very exciting
why bakersfield um just some family
things going on and i actually using a
va loan i'm saving up money i'm buying a
house
probably at the base of the sierra
nevadas really nice cool area
i mean there's a fault underneath it but
i always wanted to be in a major
earthquake
that's not fun well you may get your
wish yet
you guys are looking at me like i'm all
oh that's cause your faces are frozen
i was like why are they just staring now
we're frozen
it might be the internet oh yeah
that's all right chewie so we're moving
to bakersfield
what is what are you leaving behind you
know when you move you've been this
place for a long time
what do you leave behind shoe
nothing but just bars that won't let me
in dude i'm banned from the whole 16th
street in denver
i mean for real it's time i mean a state
gets sick of me after you know a few
years and i've been here
seven so but i want to take over
hollywood
i mean back in the day hanging out on
hollywood strip when i was on guinness
world records for a while that's where i
belonged with a microphone just asking
millennials questions like can you name
three of the brady kids
you know that's comedy dude that
definitely sounds great i'd love to send
you out to the street
and uh have you interview the people out
there but shoei would you be wearing a
mask if you went out to hollywood
boulevard do you believe in masks oh no
oh he's
right let's gone again i was gonna say
shu do you believe in
if you went out to hollywood boulevard
would you be wearing a mask do you
believe in masks
oh yeah you gotta wear a mask bro nice
definitely gotta wear masks the only way
we're gonna save society you know what i
mean
so shoe nice gets it i mean wow
i mean shoe nice is too nice i i
actually do think you're an intelligent
man
into a chair well assuming you can hear
me oh yeah yeah but look at man
i got ones that match my eyes match my
shirt
match my background that's my shoe nice
tattoo on my arm dude
oh yeah i'm all about blue that's why i
got the that's why i got the teddy fresh
jersey you know what i mean i feel yeah
you're all about the blue
baby blue the best thing that came with
your shirt dude
oh you know it's a sticker this is a
book marker
you can roll a joint on it when you're
on the city bus
hey shoe and you get the other one
and i i tried to eat it for video bro i
don't want to do that
yeah i wouldn't recommend that hey shoe
that's a sticker you know that good
evening
i just didn't want to disrespect you oh
well thank you we appreciate that
so you lived in denver for seven years
you're up and leaving to california
no friends no girlfriends oh yeah i got
i got all that bro i got a whole
family behind this curtain that just
don't want to be a part of youtube
maybe they'll be a part of it someday
let me see behind that curtain
hey i'm just like jim carrey i'm just
like will pharaoh bro
i'm just a really good actor you gotta
have a little gary busy in you to you
know
yeah you definitely got gary busy i had
a lady i had a mystic psychic lady he
said that i have the soul of robin
williams god rest his soul
he was my hero along with chris farley
we try and stay calm
and you think it's going to be a good
interview and then i'm bouncing all over
the place
right what i mean absolutely i mean i'm
living it
you live with it every day
what are you drinking i'm just curious
this is water okay good because 90 days
sober today
good congratulations i really am proud
of you i hope you you keep going chill
i never i'm never drinking again wow you
did
did somebody throw in like an audience
clapping yeah yeah yeah that was dan he
was clapping extra loud for you
every tv show you're on you when they go
to the audience and they're clapping
they pre-record that
like days before sometimes on uh
tash.now oh you know oh that's all a
scene
but when we do everything there's no
audience there
um it's just you know that's just added
in
there's no audience in the taj what a
what a sham
well not it's all studio audiences like
the clapping and everything guinness
world records go wild we did it
and the audience was behind us but all
that clapping was pre-recorded because i
guess it screws up the audio
you guys seen that one where i ate 20
birthday candles on fire in under a
minute for a guinness world record i
actually
knocked on my whole door and they said
dude you got to stay here
so what is that record for eating the
most birthday candles on well on fire
that's very niche
it's nice this guy wasn't even gonna
make the show unless me and another dude
from youtube agreed to do it and
after all these talks they finally
brought a bunch of us to california to
try and beat these stupid records like a
woman put
a hundred pairs of underwear on and off
i mean
but i failed it because they stuck the
candles in this styrofoam cup and the
styrofoam and the can
it was just a toxic mess i don't know
how he died and the cameraman seen it
he's like dude the emts were just
laughing at he goes i've seen it
oh they didn't do it they came to my
hotel yeah everybody else got sent home
they came to my hotel they said we want
you on another episode man you're just
legendary and it was so fun i said well
we got to use a cake this time not
styrofoam
and then i got the record and you
smashed it
the second time yeah that's my boy
what i'd like to do when you come out to
l.a show lasted a year
i want to find other guinness world
records we can have you break
on the show how great would that be that
would be amazing
i mean if you put me side by side with
somebody i always win because i got like
10 times the power when i'm just making
a video that's just regular eating
but like if you put me on somebody like
get like laps to l.a beast has like 10
world records i mean he just hung out
with two women that said hey we're
beginners world records
they got in office and just sets food in
front of them i'll beat all them records
and he pukes it up yeah i'm looking at
you ladies
you follow me like a little shadow bro
just like steve will do it so
hang on i think we've got a great
vertical for chewy on the show
i think we got to give you a whole
segment like shoe shoe the destroyer or
shoe the dominator
maybe even on the street we can find
people that want to see a lot of people
going yeah sorry that would be cool i
get a little delay but there's going to
be a lot of people in your fan base
i mean my fan base is like 500 potheads
so i think they'll just get along
when it comes down to comedy i was just
born to make people laugh
and just i i don't even need a script
dude everything is ad-lib to me
and i mean i mean like baba
there you go well papa shui um i can't
wait for
you're coming out in two weeks right
yeah i'll i'll be
you'll see me i'll make a video in l.a
probably sometime
the end of next week tuesday locked down
in
somebody's gotta go somewhere i'm gonna
be somewhere and then everything else is
just gonna come together like
magic bro um why is it that you like
when you post a video you always erase
it
i'm done with that bro that was that was
a drunken you know bipolar let's get
some opiates on saturday and do molly on
monday i'm just all business now dude
thank god
why look at the black when you look at
the past when the future
oh laughs yeah no i just wanted to
i was just trying to download the
phenomenon because you would upload a
video and then
like clockwork you would remove it would
it just be like you would sober up and
then be embarrassed by the video or what
oh no never embarrass what it is is that
you would never want a video
to not have as many views as the one
prior to it
that's why some people that they get
that million views and like gunk and
arrow
oh i'm going to be a legend forever and
you know once he lost that whole h3h
street glamour
you know he's just going to go back to
like five six thousand views and his
whole channel
oh sorry that's so i i never imagined
that's why
go ahead i'm not sure you should follow
that rule
that's not going to work for you
well yeah yeah yeah we're business now
i'm sorry
so it's not true that you should erase
it if it's got less
views from the last video because your
view your views will go up and down
that's natural
yeah also youtube that's probably
true that's probably true but um i want
to also ask you guys something too
after i get to my internship is i'm
going to be training in bakersfield
to fight in mma fights so you guys laugh
i'm 53
and i'll take out the whole ufc
heavyweight division
but maybe if i have like my shorts i'll
have h3h3 on one ass
cheek and sure
can we get a tf on your forehead i would
sponsor you for that
tattooed i don't know obviously just
careful
she wouldn't do that she wouldn't do
that i don't know why shu
just picks up and bounces i think he's
going to put the tf
on his forehead yeah pretty sure but he
does occasionally
and what's left is basically like an old
brown chair and a curtain that can only
be described as here's my resume
so you guys i got it i take it off with
a shot
i do this all the time on my live stream
i go live every day
you just take one of these things what
is it
so just a layer of skin but that's good
to shed like a snake bro oh my god
just sure you could probably use a paper
towel it was a steel wool
like oh that was just steel wool
would it be on top where are they now
and now that they don't have to pay for
a 2800
itinerary flying me out and back i'm
just going to show up at his studio i
know how to get right to the gate
i love to film that to you though just
blindfold me i'll be like this all right
you sit me down
on the purple couch i interview that
daniel walks me out the door a couple of
blocks and
boom is it okay you rolled me out of a
van dude
just slow down like 15 miles an hour
just dummy yeah
yeah is that okay if we throw a pillow
case on your head and throw you in an
unmarked van
hold on bro i gotta take my bite in this
man i just that's the only way i can
stay healthy
had a piece of paper that said vitamin a
d and b and he ate the piece of paper
for those just listening
we're going to get along just great now
that we got over everything of the past
yeah i'm sure there's more drama ahead
i'm a business i'm a businessman bro i'm
going to be paying you guys to have me
in your studio that's how i work you
know
well you were very upset that we didn't
pay you last time isn't that right
hey where's that
this is how i sleep every night bro
so i love silk dude i mean this is just
i'm just like
wow get away from me i'm alert i'm not
that type of guy
[Music]
well uh shoe um you're like kind of like
a prop comic
aren't you you're kind of like a shoe
you're kind of like a carrot top a shoe
a shoe bottom if you would please
did you just say never top carrot top is
a steroid freaking nature he
does look like he does kind of look wild
doesn't
he i don't know i look like john c
riley bro shaken babe talladega nights
well i was just comparing you because
you're kind of like a prop comic i think
wow so much for your wi-fi to handle
he says yeah i know you move too much
your wi-fi can't render
fast enough you gotta not move
otherwise we can't make out your frames
you didn't hear the dial up before we
went online
still on dial-up yeah well you listen
uh our the connection is pretty bad i'm
not gonna lie so it's kind of somewhat
difficult to have a conversation
but i think we've we've we've covered
enough we've got the shoe nice update we
love what we see we're excited to see
you i think we got some good ideas too i
want to send you out on the street
shoe nice to the destroyer competition
ow bro if i ever get injured i don't
have to sue
anybody i got veterans medical for life
dude i can lose a leg making a video
that's good to know
that's good to know i mean that's that's
really good to know i'll use that
we're emma our war heroes man we need to
be together
on youtube brother absolutely
[Laughter]
all right chewie uh you're still
crushing it on cameo
oh dude i gotta i can never stop
thanking you guys enough bro
that's awesome cameo it's just you know
five grand a month dude minimum wow
that's terrific that's terrific so
youtube is my weed my you choose my weed
money dude
so cameo next time you talk to that ceo
susan tell her she's gotta
take the notification bell right out of
the equation we never needed it before
everybody that's subscribed to your
channel gets the video whether they like
it or not
okay i'll tell if she said that
so shoe 22 on cameo right let me write
what she did to me
cool lady susan a shoe next 22 on cameo
right
yeah yeah that's the that's where that's
where you'll find him
straight shoe nice i'm shoe nice 22 on
tick tock i'm about ready to hit 100
000 subscribers and i'm gonna be
marketed there i'll be a marketing
partner
yeah and you wear their [ __ ] shoe do you
have any limit on what you'll say
on cameo for example if somebody asks
you to
recruit for i don't know al qaeda would
you do that or would you will you say
anything anytime somebody comes in and
says anything
racist just say this say the n word i
say nutella on their mom's ass
i change it all up and it pisses them
off and you take their money
i used to shut down a lot of um kkk and
racist channels on instagram
that's the one thing i got to tell you i
do have a contract out of my head
so i'll never reveal where you guys are
you have a concept on your head wow
no i'm just
[Laughter]
you're not even in my life anymore what
are you even living here for
for sorry is out of frame arguing with
marge simpson
oh thanks all right
julie oh i got a door i found it i found
a deer the other one
she was up and out of his seat again
what did he found he found a deer
yeah there's not a
hey doggie what's his name this
is hazel she's a girl but her on stage
name is ears
hazel what a sweetheart you played gizmo
she played gizmo in a broadway version
of gremlins
she does she does ren and stimpy oh
stupid
so cute yeah
almost 11. oh wow has she been with you
how has she been with you like the whole
time seven years seven years oh and
that's so
beautiful that's so precious you that
makes me
that makes me more and dear to you that
knowing you've had a dog for seven years
dude i love the animals more than kids
dude
i love animals more than humans i miss
my dogs more than my exes you know i
know yeah
i feel like i feel like i would be
sadder if my dogs died than most people
i know
oh my god look at them playing yeah that
is so
precious yeah they're the best i love
them they're so cute
i gotta hold back the tears i ate all my
tissue last
night
all right chewy i gotta let you go let's
end on top
we'll see you we'll see you in a couple
of weeks all over trees he messaged me
when i was trolling him
i'll box him any day dude
put that in the title i'm looking for
oliver trees
all right i'll let him know i don't know
that i don't know you want to mess with
that character
you can't wait to get on the payroll
just kidding i'm paying you
yeah yeah and i'll send you an invoice
all right oh he's out
he just hung up all right
okay ladies and gentlemen
well always a pleasure having shu on
think there's a lot of potential good
content there to be made with him
competing
talking to people on the street i just
he's an entertainer at heart at his
heart
he definitely is and i'm really proud of
him being sober
for so long she was she's the guy
she was the guy um
on thursday so it would be out on friday
is that right uh
all gas no breaks i don't know if you
guys
if you're not aware of this channel you
should be he
is a super funny
he goes out into wild places and just
interviews people he's got this really
fantastic way of interviewing people
where they're so forthcoming
he did this one interview during the
riots and was it minneapolis
yeah where he went inside a burning like
target
and was just interviewing the writers
and i'm just it's it's great that he got
picked up by absolutely which is tim and
eric's production company for a show
the guys he's crushing it he's he's
fantastic
he's gonna be joining us on thursday and
uh
can't wait to talk with him so that's
coming up this week
um and that's pretty much it for the
issue podcast
hope you learned a lot i think we
learned a lot we covered a lot of of
we covered a lot of ground today
um no no we
we we we backtracked
would you say we no i was going to say
whatever you're going to ask me
you want mexican food whatever it is i
knew do you want to
uh swim tonight yes nope it's too late
you can't
swim tonight yeah we swim for exercise
all right but you ela's usually like i
gotta
bag ethan i don't want it to sound that
pathetic
i'm glad you're doing it though because
we recently i'm not lying i had a
conversation about your pool and you
said you hadn't used it yet
i've tried a lot since then okay well
good because
i've been using it several times a week
that's awesome
but it was like the winter it was cold
and now it's the summer and
we've been using it a lot was that
acceptable to you dan yes thank you i'll
give you a pass thank you very much
so eli does not want to swim tonight do
you want to
not get pizza tonight
yes no you said whatever i ask the
answer is no
so you don't want to swim and you do
want to get pizza tonight
got her
got her got her oh god this is so
stupid ending
what else is there to say i mean nobody
watches anyway right
thursday's gonna be great we also have
another interesting
guest the following week um the party
bros
chad and jt the party bros who are out
trying to hand out mass they're going to
city council
lobbying for parties in the hollywood
hills these guys are up to
all kinds of shenanigans we love it and
they are coming
on on [ __ ] next week yes sir
ian zach anything to add
party on dude
zack who's your favorite porn star oh my
god
rosie palm and her five sisters
the [ __ ] is that rosie palm and her five
sisters oh that's your hand
do you have a favorite porn star
you know that's immoral man i don't
partake in that
that's against god yeah i expected what
would it would it be kim kardashian
i mean that's what i was gonna say but
he thinks that's disrespectful
well how so even what i don't know i
don't
i mean she did it willingly it's not
like you know i mean i remember for the
longest time she was like the most
popular search for years on pornhub
you remember that and she still i think
she still is she's up there
let me see most popular searches on
pornhub you want to look like in the us
or globally
i think in the us most accurate let's
keep it in the us
top circuit i think she i think she won
something when i was at the pornhub
awards that's true
oh for real what did she win um
uh i don't remember i can't remember
what just flashed on screen there for a
second
i don't know what you're talking about
bring that back bring that back i put
the zoom back on i didn't see it oh i
got to bring these
these guys up right
i i was just saying i don't watch porn
because you know
my man's always watching
jesus was black ian and i think it's
absolutely racist that you're
appropriating
he looks a little middle eastern there
he looks like
white as [ __ ] that's like the whitest
we've ever seen jesus what no
you've wasn't jesus definitely whiter
jesus than that
but jesus well uh he's from palestine
right
well i guess but i don't know why do
people say he's black
he was probably just middle eastern he's
probably just looked arab arabic
or middle eastern right ian
i don't know my jesus well somebody does
this drawing that gets shown a lot
what did jesus actually
look like and i don't know why people
always show this because i think it's
just he looks strange it looks like a
mug shot
like this is what he was a criminal
somebody always shows this painting
as like this is what jesus probably
looked like
and just looks like some dude yeah
yes yeah i guess that makes sense he's
got a go team [ __ ]
they always depict him as incredibly
handsome it's what about this guy
yeah i mean looks israeli
yeah he does so it makes sense
this guy looks like he just looks like
an israeli
dad who's like super like harsh
but yeah he probably did look like this
all right um top porn stars just to go
oh belle delphine what the f she was
number four
dude she is so huge top uh
searches in 2019 one amateur
two alien i [ __ ] you not alien
let me say that again alien you're
saying that these are the top
searches okay well i guess maybe because
all that area 51
meme last year i guess i mean
alien number three was pov number four
was
belle delphine oh cause probably because
she that troll she did
yeah right but still you to appreciate
how much traffic she drove i mean
pornhub is one of the most popular sites
in the world
she's a marketing genius five speaking
of her we should give an update
because we we did uh talk about the
packages
in the last episode this can't be right
six is mature there's more people
searching for
grandmas than lesbians that can't be
right
that cannot be right
here okay take it up and take it up wait
hold on i don't know what the
what they're on about this is most
search terms for 2019
japanese was number one hentai two
lesbian three there you go
milf iv korean asian damp
these dudes love asians the top five
spots is asian korean hentai and
japanese that's
crazy step mob massage anal
ebony big ass teen threesome anime
public cream pie big tits
chinese makes an appearance
i didn't know that there was such a
fascination with asian women
lana rhodes number one don't blink
either
i'm falling asleep mia khalifa
riley reed it's not that interesting to
just hear you read stuff it's like
reading it
and then your boy uh zach i know you
know this guy
jordy el nino i remember you
he is the most searched male porn star
by far
which is a guy he looks like he's like
15 but he's got this huge [ __ ] and he's
like looks like he's like
a middle schooler you see even how it's
just a chair
i'm vibing on that oh yeah
he was leaving all right all right
well then i guess that does it hey folks
i guess oh my god look at oh i should
show it the screen i'm sorry
i should have just that's what i was
saying well just tell me to drag the
window
well i think you know by now no that's
why i was saying it's not that
interesting just to hear your reads
no i wanted people to watch it united
states is
killing it on the porn well that's just
pornhub
time spent per visit thailand 11 minutes
do people spend 10 minutes on part up
yeah that sounds about right
this is still not that interesting i'm
fascinated by this
you know mississippi they have a bite
this is epic
mississippians spend the most time on
page
those guys talk about this like a year
and a half ago
when this like came out or yeah i think
it was like we did
it was less and it was better specific
most people are jerking off at midnight
the least amount of people are jerking
off for
5 a.m that's awesome
this is not that interesting it's so
funny
like if you're jerking off at 5am you
know you're just like the pathetic
outlier and if you're jerking off at
midnight god bless you
right before bed peak hours
most popular day to jerk off um
friday's the least popular day to jerk
off that interests me
saturday oh sunday is the most popular
day to jerk off
probably because everyone's like [ __ ]
it's monday
you know what i mean monday's next um
japanese killing it lesbian yadda yadda
yadda
america loves lesbians russia loves
hentai
we've literally talked about this
exactly what is israel into
um what's this ebony wait that's israel
oh here it is yeah yeah it's probably
too tiny wait what's orange
arab oh weird interesting
i guess maybe that makes sense i could
see israelis want to jerk off to arabs
because it's like exotic and different
than whatever
uh okay most oh here we go
most searched term for pornhub gay now
we're talking
korean so even the gay guys like the
asian
asians interesting korean
japanese black daddy i wonder what's
daddy porn just like dad
straight what the f asian twink
i would expect twink to be higher
wouldn't you ela
camp buddies is top trending awesome
wait what camp buddy
[Laughter]
most viewed gay category oh straight
guys
you know that's interesting that that's
like a thing in the gay community
because that was yeah the whole thing
about james charles
hey jeffree star like you want what you
can't get in
fruit yeah
straight guys maybe they just find
just staring at me all cute most
searched for gay porn stars evil take
note
zevel goodl is the number one star by
far
look that up uh later most food
categories by gender oh
women's favorite okay so this i am
actually really interested in
women number one is a lesbian thoughts
on that evo
i guess that kind of makes sense it does
can you explain unpack that for me
well the lesbian oh because it's like
women looking for women
yeah i think a lot of straight women
watch lesbian sex
i got you ian and i got that in there
and i think what is ian is ian
what are you doing in there what did he
do he's asleep he's in bed
open zoom oh you guys aren't seeing it
no no
no because eli made me close it because
oh here because ethan was just oh he
did it all right well i can't even see
you so
nice joke lesbian is number one with
women
popular with women is pop the second
most popular
pretty talented with the zoom background
comedy
yeah we should just do a whole new job
and zoom background comedy
[Laughter]
uh would you guess that the second most
popular category with women
is popular with women that's the name of
the category
oh but number three is japanese
everybody loves the japanese
that's crazy i i think just based off of
the uh
geographic map that you put up there i
mean
they're asians is the biggest population
in the world so it's it's really just
people search it's a lot of no these are
americans no it's not
or does it say um you think that
no go go back up to the map i'll show
you what i'm talking about
oh look at everything in china japanese
yeah look at all of china wait so all of
china wants to [ __ ] japanese people
well i think it's probably just because
it's the most common asian category on
porn why would they allow such data to
skew the whole map
that's not skewing there's just there's
a billion chinese people
and they all want japanese people this
is really the worst conversation no it's
not
how dare you i just don't think it's
that surprising that the the largest
ethnic group in the world
searches for its its own ethnic group
you know what i mean
but i would assume that they're using
their own porn sites
why i guess not everybody uses pornhub
man guys i do think it's worth noting
that
of the women's favorites big dick is
very low
on the register there you go
it's actually at the same position
between well why would men
be searching for actually more women
want one big dick than
men which i guess you know the same
placement in order though
yeah right that is interesting we all
like big dick just a little bit
yeah just a little bit there's more
women watching hentai than big dick
there's no gang bang on demands but
there is on the women's
yeah i think i could see but uh
let's see ebony anal anal's pretty high
up
a milf women watching enough at the same
spot too
anime anal on men and women
oh it looks like men eked out the desire
for anal a little bit more
i want to talk about feet oh here we go
uh viewed more often by women compared
to men [ __ ] looking
that is so vulgar
a scissoring is on here how are we going
to put any of this in the episode yeah
why
are we going why we're just talking
scissoring is on here
people actually want scissoring oh
bisexual mail
double penetration women want to see
double penetration that
that's fascinating to me
oh you see lana rhodes number one oh
whoa whoa whoa the women are looking out
for jordi el nino
poya that's interesting that they want
to look find that little 15 year old
middle schooler
i want to show you a picture of him
because he really looks like a little
kid
in fact let me google it and hopefully
oh god jordy
hold on get off your screen el nino i
just want to show you his face
what's his name uh zach i know you know
what jordi el nino just say
uh papoya oh l a oil
like chicken oh here he is here's a
non-pornographic photo
oh jesus here let me just
wait i want to show you like without
okay please don't be porn okay that's
him that's him
pretty badass he's number one
all right that's enough guys ian are you
there
[Music]
his chair yeah it's like his camera
froze
ian did your camera freeze
i'm kind of sick you done
wrap it up i don't know maybe i have the
flu or something we're done
we're done we're done all right bye
bye tatty
[Music]
[Music]